hi shelby hi steve here we are again
uh so the last time we were talking
about the many stories and it is
important that the voice be pleasant and
not run too fast and we're gonna make
sure that that is the case wherever we
can
you know we have so many people involved
in those
uh it's difficult to control them all
but we will definitely make an effort
um
one of the things about i know the many
stories it's not like they're not
gripping
uh
they are relatable though i will say i i
can't remember which number it was uh
but one of the many stories i went
through this week talks about you know
um this guy who's got a new girlfriend
he wants to cook her a meal he goes to
the store he doesn't buy anything he
leaves and go gets pizza
i was like i can relate to that
you know these stories were written by a
girl who was a english teacher canadian
girl teaching english in japan okay i
personally like them i think there are
little elements of humor like the guy
who has a date with a girl and they sit
there and they look at each other have
you had that one yeah i think that was
the last one i went through this week
yeah yeah no and there's others like
that that they're not like they're
little vignettes and they have often uh
somewhat surprising and like the guy
well you haven't come across them yeah
there's a whole bunch of them amazing
so they're they're not totally without
interest they're not like a bunch of
sentences thrown together sure right and
they don't like to pretend to be
anything they're little stories so i
think she did a fabulous joke by myself
i i don't mind them
but the voice has to be pleasant and it
has to be at the right speed but but it
is this it's you know what
like i was in the lumber business
and when we did quality control we did
sort of and it's any manufacturing
process you do a random sampling
so you know you take 100 pieces of
lumber out of the line and you measure
them for moisture content or not size or
whatever it might be and and those
hundred pieces
which you pulled out of the line is a
small percentage a couple of percent of
the total
number that's running across your
production line but it is an indication
of what's in that batch of lumber
and language is a bit like that like
you can take any sampling of the
language it's going to have a lot of the
characteristics of the language
so if you like the many stories don't
cover a lot of vocabulary uh eventually
to acquire the vocabulary you need you
have to read widely and you have to
listen widely but the essence of the
language the structure the frequent
verbs the frequent conjunctions they're
all there
that little sampling
is quite representative so if you can
master those things and of course i
shouldn't ever use the word master but
it's a place where you can go back and
train and train and train on sort of the
essential
you know bits and pieces you still have
to go to the you know the broader range
of things music cooking and politics and
history to get a broader vocabulary but
the many stories i i just can't stress
enough how much they've changed my
approach to language learning and i use
them to start in a language and then i
go back
to review to refresh to bring my grammar
up to speed and so forth yeah no i
the more that i'm
uh listening to them and reading them
and especially just listening to them
like having them as background noise
like i i don't use my dishwasher for
example so when i wash the dishes i'm
listening to the mini stories and um
sometimes when i'm you know working out
or doing laundry uh very riveting things
i'm doing around my house
um exactly the
i find that even when i am not
you know fully
comprehending every single thing in the
mini stories
it is going into my brain because
then when i'm giving it my full
attention i can actually understand it
and even more surprising i'm starting to
be able to produce a sentence with the
correct structure
so i think of it a lot as like
you know the way i learned english as a
native english speaker i mean for the
first couple years of my life i'm sure
um i did not understand any anything
that any anyone was saying and over time
you just start to
to learn because you're exposed to it so
much so
one thing i've started doing now is uh
if i'm listening because i listen to
them in arabic or persian or whatever
italian
and as you said it's it's easier to
listen while you're doing something else
something that doesn't require a lot of
brain power yes
it's easier to do that rather than just
sit down and i'm not going to listen
because then you start fidgeting and you
want to do something else but if you're
already doing something else then you're
quite content at least i am i think you
are quite content to listen
i'm also quite able to repeat while
listening
yes so that's something i can also do i
don't answer the questions like they ask
me a question i don't try to answer them
because that then i have to think so
we're just repeating you don't have to
think but at least it forces you to say
what you're hearing
and i think it focuses your attention
better
but that's all the more reason why we
have to make sure that they're not
spoken too quickly otherwise you don't
have a chance to uh to repeat what you
hear
[Music]
right okay now the many stories of
course we go through them here and
i wouldn't say they get more difficult
the only real difference is that uh
after lesson 20 they have the past tense
okay and whereas the first 20 lessons is
everything is in the present tense no
the past tense isn't necessarily more
difficult than the present tense
but at least in the first 20 stories you
know you're in the present tense
when we come past the first 20 lessons
not only will you have the past tense
you'll have the imperfect you'll have
the future you'll have the conditional
you'll have all those different tenses
and and i don't think it's more
difficult because to my mind you just
relate these to meaning to meaning you
don't have to have the term
plu perfect or conditional or subject
you just related to me so that's
something we have to look forward to yes
but for the time being we're not there
yet well i'm very excited for that
okay
uh
we'll see what happens all right perfect
okay so i'm actually still in the lesson
from last video
so over here on the side if i click on
the link mini stories it's a great way
to show sort of
your progress so of course also the the
view course is kind of a useful place to
go
to get at you know if you want to go
your year around less than 10 and you
want to jump to less than 30 then you go
to view course and you can quickly find
it by the way i guess you haven't done
number six yet but we won't go there
today that's strange i think it's maybe
i just didn't hit the complete oh okay
that's probably why i'm sure i didn't
skip it
this isn't school so
um okay so you can randomly select
something
okay so but the point is we're going to
do an experiment here we're going to go
into a lesson that you haven't seen
before
okay so i'm going to grab this last last
time you write a lesson that you had
already done yes exactly so
number 17 is speaking to me let's just
give this one a whirl see what we have
here
okay
okay
um
just get rid of this blue word
is to return
and you would it's like re-enter right
we would identify it with in english but
it means like la jolte scolaire is the
return to school like now there's a lot
of talk of our kids going back to school
blah blah blah
they talk about you know school begins
again
uh so
is to return
it doesn't mean re-enter like he's not
re-entering
he comes back montre you there is
another verb
he could they could say
you could also say that but it's more
common to say
oh and both would work for like a person
returning
i was wondering if this uh is an
all-encompassing return because there's
also like i could return to you
something that i borrowed from you
yeah i'm saying no
there's a different word for that
the word there is
render oh okay okay yeah i learned
render but i didn't i didn't know it was
also used in that context
uh notice over there on your vocabulary
on the right hand side it tells you that
it's present tense
it says it's je which is wrong
but the jer form
and the ila form are the same so our
automatic
you know
uh so it's not wrong it's just not right
in this context right
it tells you what the infinitive is it
tells it it's a verb
and uh
you could go
yeah this tag
doesn't seem necessary
no
i mean you don't need to take you can
remove it yeah
i could also add
yeah you can add a tag
but uh il yeah that's good
and uh let's look at the uh dictionaries
conjugation reverso click on that
because i think it's such a good
dictionary
so there you can see that the jeff form
and the ill form are the same
and if you
it's not such an issue now because in
the first lessons everything is in the
present tense but later on when we're
into all kinds of different tenses it'll
be useful to go to context reversal just
to make sure you have the right tense
here
yes
okay look forward to it all right
okay that's a tough one for me this
those pronunciations
oh yeah those are good but all these
pronunciation things it's it's all
practice like
right now you've only been added a few
weeks it's tough six months from now
it'll be just second nature all right
here's hoping yeah
okay
the translator chose to go to le jour
which is fine
every day two is like a really common
[Music]
uh
it's commonly found in a lot of phrases
right actually i'm wrong i'm wrong
because each day would be
so every day is too late
she's right where do you know i'm
usually there you go
okay
from
you could say in his car downstairs but
means by
[Music]
but he
comes back or gets home from work by car
onward to you
yeah it's a good phrase to have
okay
so
why is this not plural
which one is that
what's yours
yeah what's here
lot of
don't forget that au is always o
i know i keep on wanting to pronounce it
like in certain you will for a long time
the autobahn
great
that's a good way to remember that
okay now one thing i should also point
out and remember everything i point out
is just to help you notice things
because you're going to forget and but
you'll notice it again
boku is like always boku do
um
like we say many cars
but they say many of cars
in other words if it wasn't boku do
it would be boku do what you
many cars
many
and i could think of it like in english
uh if it instead of being many if
it was a lot because we always have to
say a lot of yes exactly very good point
the other thing i would
click on ilia are you you're comfortable
with ilia
yes
there is there are right that's a really
good phrase though yeah it's very useful
to have india
it's like i in spanish
yes
very useful
you know and it's very annoying like i
can remember when i was into russian and
of course what looks to us like a p is
an r in russian and six months into
russian
i would look up the dictionary under the
p section like it just takes so long
for certain new habits to form so don't
get upset if you continue to say boku
because you will
and you'll say auto route instead of
you will and then all of a sudden you'll
notice that you're not doing it anymore
and
uh how long did it take you before or
are you still having a hard time with
the russian pea no not at all not at all
i can't remember but some things you
know some habits form quickly and some
habits like in russian all of their
difficult uh you know case endings and
that is still difficult i make mistakes
i did a video in russian the other day
and i got some criticism for my grammar
and stuff so
different things the sock in at
different times there's no predicting
there's no predicting we had a youtube
commenter ask what is the hardest
language that you've ever learned
do you have a straightforward answer for
that there are
difficult for different reasons i mean
arabic is difficult persian is easier
slavic languages are difficult for their
grammar
um
but you have some vocabulary in common
arabic
very little they're all different
they're all difficult for different
reasons but the romance language is like
french spanish are for an english
speaker easier
so because i don't want to i don't want
to make it too easy for you i want you
to get overconfident
i think what we want to do now is to
head into the next set of many stories
where we are dealing with lots of
different tenses all right so all right
okay bye for now
[Music]
you